خلال الايام الماضيه اصبح حارس منتخب
العراقي السابق نور صبري حديث مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بسبب صوره نشرها
احتفالا بدخول ابنته كليه طب الصوره فتحت
باب المتنمرين على مصراعيه لتطالب كلماتهم
المزعجه ابنه اللاعب دفعه لاخفاء
التعليقات على الصوره من حسابه على
انستجرام ورغم التنمر فان اصوات كثيره
دافعت عن صدري واكدتنا صبري مثال للاب
العظيم الذي يفتخر بابنته كذلك فقد اكد
المدافعون عن صبري ان التعليقات منافيه
للاخلاق بل دخيله على المجتمع العراقي
مشددين على ضروره التصدي لها لكي لا تتكرر
مثل هذه الافعال
[موسيقى]
شو صار يعني ليش التنمر تحديدا يا نور كيف
شفت انت هذا التنمر في الحقيقه يعني من
الشخصيات او من الناس اللي
متفهم للوضع وين كنت حزين لطريقه التعامل
مع الصوره وهو ليس بالجديد بالنسبه لي انه
انا انزل صور مع اولادي بشكل مستمر احتفل
بهم واحتفي بهم في كل نجاح يقدموه لانفسهم
بالتالي يعني هذا انا اشعر بفخر كبير
واتعرض للفتره والاخرى لامور تخص خاصه لما
يكون بناتي بالصوره يعني اولادي ماكو
عليها مشكله لكن لما يكون الموضوع يخص
البنت هنا المساله يعني مختلفه يمكن اكو
جزء انا فرحان بيه وسعيد هو طريقه تعامل
الناس او رده فعل الناس هذا يمكن يفتح باب
للتعامل اخر مع المراه ومع البنت يعني
بالتحديد لانه احنا بالفتره الماضيه ولا
لا يزال انه المراه والبنت يعني تتعرض
دائما لكثير من الاعتداءات والتحرشات اذا
كانت على المستوى الشارع على مستوى الاهل
منع ورفض دائما البنت دائما
انت اليوم تصف حاله يعاني منها الكثيرون
اليوم في المجتمعات خصوصا من جراء تعليقات
سوشيال ميديا كمان شو تفسيرك لهذه الحاله
على السوشيال ميديا عم بنلاقي جيوش
الكترونيه عملاقي اشخاص يقومون ويتجراون
بكل وقاحه على نشر تعليقات موسيقى واعطاء
رايهم وهم اصلا مختبئين فوق الشاشه وفوق
نعاني يعني بصراحه بصريح العباره احنا
نعاني معاناه كبيره مع الناس يعني حتى
واحنا مثلا خلينا نقول نسوي عملنا الخاص
اعلاناتنا الخاصه شغل اي شيء هناك معترضين
لكل شيء وكانه العمليه هي عباره عن لا يجب
انتقد اي قضيه مهما تكون بدون ما يعرف
المحتوى الحقيقي بدون ما يعرف في العبره
من هذا الفيديو او الصوره او الحكمه اللي
تنزل عن طريق السوشيال ميديا اعتقد
المشكله الحقيقيه هو عدم وجود الرقابه
خاصه احنا بالعراق عندنا مشكله بعدم وجود
الرقابه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لان
الموضوع بالحقيقه لما يتحول يعني يصير
متطرف يعني ويصير ديني وهذه الان تلعب
بعقول الشباب هذه مساله جدا خطيره يعني
يعني احنا كنعاني منها بشكل كبير لكن انا
اعتقد ايضا على عاتق المعنيين المسؤولين
انه يكون هناك رقابه مثل باقي دول الخليج
هناك رقابه على كل كلمه تكتب لانه احنا
بصراحه نتعرض الى تهديد ولا نتعرض حتى الى
سب وشتم باللي عوائلنا بشتى الوسائل
فاعتقد السبب الرئيسي هو غياب الرقه
[موسيقى]